Okay.
Should be live here. Hello folks.
We got some experiments to check on
today.
Oh, actually.
That's not bad.
I mean there's some real um
We got real results.
Hey Arch, how's it going?
All right, well.
I suppose um
We fix up constellation, we pull these
results.
Uh at some point during the day I'm
going to have to go figure out
how we can get Spencer involved with
running some of these baselines.
Take a quick look over the to-do list.
Yeah, I didn't get either of these two
done.
So why don't we work a little bit on
constellation
and a little bit on this stuff today,
huh?
That'll be nice.
Another day, another grind, yep.
That works.
Oh, ho.
Well, well, well.
I don't think these are the actual
scores though.
You see?
We get skipping logs, right? Bad data
and the num metrics.
I don't like losing data. Let's figure
out why we're doing that.
Where are we getting num metrics from,
man?
I should run at
do this.
You
R and
I know RMS, I don't know LA, Spearman or
Yeah.
I think I'm supposed to know what one of
those is and I don't know what any of
those are. Okay, one of those is mean
average error, I think.
One of those root mean square something.
I don't know what
Yeah, I don't know what those are, my
guy.
That's some supervised learning stuff, I
think.
My thanks.
Environments have their own metrics and
then you have some general losses as
well.
Deeper narrow nets have some benefits
wide and flat ones.
Um
It depends what you mean by deeper.
There are some papers showing very bad
uh very bad flop efficiency scaling but
some data efficiency scaling under some
settings with larger networks.
Empirically most of the time when we're
trying to solve the task faster
um you don't need you need more than
like a two-layer MLP or something.
But you don't need anything too crazy.
Like we're typically operating with
between two and six um
min grew layers or one or two LSTM
layers.
You absolutely do need memory though.
Memory is required.
Okay, so these are different.
Agent steps.
I don't know why these don't have loss
metrics.
>> Okay.
Nothing is lost.
It's awesome to be a last researcher in
the field in the stream. Yeah.
It's kind of one of the fun things about
this, right?
All right, so this is what we got back
from a neural MMO. You can ignore the
bottom left one at the moment.
Look at this. These are your train
curves. You can kind of see them, right?
This is only 3e9 for some reason.
I don't know if this is correct.
I'm going to stick a breakpoint down
here.
Okay, see we have a 5.6 score on here,
right?
And then this should be like 20 bill,
Yeah, this is 20 bill, so
I don't know why we're not actually
getting the data that we expect to be
getting here.
Yeah, so it's not showing score
correctly at all.
you can do with
I mean these are not trivial networks to
be clear like
you can't just get away with a super
basic MLP.
The architecture does actually have an
effect.
And a lot of the work I did for this
update was on the architecture.
So this is now the thing we got to
figure out.
Why are we not seeing our full data?
On substring, right? We want um
get
Okay, look at this.
Uh we have to scroll up, but look found
we actually do find the scores here,
right?
Wait, something is weird because look,
this is an agent steps, right?
up time
agent steps
This axis doesn't change.
You see that?
But it's here, too.
Ah, int overflow.
It's actually int overflow. You see it?
That's super funny.
Hm.
Yeah, that's um
it's actually integer overflow.
All right, well, we have to use doubles
and stuff for parameters.
integers for parameters
I forgot that we have billions and
billions of steps.
Just don't work for that.
So.
>> Are you really going to remove UV from
popper? So, to be clear and niche, no,
I'm not going to remove the option to
have any python because we're still
going to have either a torch or tiny red
or whatever the hell people want. There
will be a python option most likely cuz
otherwise nobody uses stuff.
Um, but what I would like to have is I
would like to have our native high
performance code. I'd like to be able to
run our training and our sweeps without
having to touch python. That I think
would be really good.
Hey Vault, how's it going?
We're getting so close to being done.
Here, let me show you this.
Let me show you how cool constellation
is.
Oops.
I'm fixing an an overflow error on it
right now.
But like I ran some neural MMO
experiments overnight. Here's the data.
You know, we get all the data points in.
And uh, you know, we can do stuff like
gamma versus perf.
Actually, there are only a couple good
values of gamma it's found on these
runs.
And we can do all sorts of nice analysis
now.
Yeah, I'll get you excited about this.
Um, I think that we're going to be able
to crush inferno once we set it up.
And um, the cool thing about inferno is
there all sorts of limitations you can
impose, right? So, we can try to do can
it do inferno on a pure?
Uh, can it do a no pillar inferno,
right?
Like all sorts of cool stuff we can do
as a challenge once we beat it.
What do you use to make these graphs? C.
This is our own new plotting library, my
guy.
This is uh, one of the things we're
adding for our constellation.
Constellation's the new plotting
library, yeah.
Um, so you have like all these nice
tools.
3D, 2D.
Copies hypers to your clipboard nicely.
This will be a tease me. There's also
there's other tools down here to look
nicer once we have more data loaded in.
And uh, this is all just raylib and C
and a couple basic shaders.
Speed runs and all? Yeah.
Speed runs should just happen as well.
Oh gosh.
If we're going to do speed runs,
I'm going to have to go get that GM task
myself so I know what I'm talking about,
aren't I?
I just have the cape. Though I got it.
You know, I got it before we had all the
modern like super overpowered gear that
makes it a lot easier.
It'd be way easier with like infliction
gauntlets and stuff.
I actually I think that there was justy
in the game.
I remember I came up with a really weird
strategy for inferno. Like I came up
with a weird gear set that nobody used.
Like I think I had eternal boots on for
inferno.
If I recall.
There was like some weird mage accuracy
breakpoint I found.
Now, inferno's very cool.
RS stream after 40. I mean, we got this,
dude.
On the side monitor.
Automatically promotes.
Okay, so it does just I that does work
for double.
Yeah, the RS one is going to be so
freaking cool.
I'm very excited.
It's like my uh,
that's my motivation now to like
hurry the hell up with this.
And don't get me wrong, chess is going
to kick ass too, Jess. And I think more
people are going to get excited about
chess.
But I'm going to
be having a really good
you know.
>> Finally make an end one thought for
that. Oh, yeah.
Recursive self-improvement. Um
That's like one of those out there
things where if I just got sick of doing
this crap and like doing
I mean, I could go way off the deep end
and just decide, yeah, I'm going to
figure out why that doesn't work.
It's kind of interesting that that
doesn't work in some sense, right?
Why does he knows are valuable for
chess?
I honestly don't know, Jess.
I think that it should be something that
we can play with quite a bit with 40
though.
That's way faster.
RLN hackathon
Nobody new puffer.
RLMs
Oh, man.
Doesn't work in principle. No, it
definitely does work in principle cuz
like your proof of this is me. I'm doing
it right now.
Right? I've gotten way better at what I
do in the last couple of years.
A puffer fish
That's a fish.
Nice puffer.
Not really a big fan of having
everything be double.
I wonder if there's anything else we can
do.
If I just divide all of them
What if I just divide all the agent
steps by million?
It's just
cuz it's just like the models are dumb.
It's all theater, man.
I think it would be better to keep it
all in um
Uh yes in principle, that's not the type
of stuff we can do here though.
Like working in text space is just
tough.
I like the thing is
in my mind I honestly kind of don't care
because like
there are enough other problems I can
work on that are simply not being
addressed by the mainstream what
everybody is hemorrhaging money to do.
Um
that are also incredibly important like
you're not going to just have the
language model
go solve uh RL on
low
low level physics environments
molecular dynamics um
a lot of what my long-term interests are
like material science
biological sim
uh industrial automation like these are
things where
I find it very unlikely. You'd basically
have to fully automate intelligence with
the language models in order for it to
solve that and then it would basically
just have to do what I'm doing now but
better.
And so far what I've seen is that the
companies have put tens of billions of
dollars into this, hundreds of billions
of dollars into this in fact.
And uh the models just suck.
So
um in contrast and I put
few hundred thousand dollars into this
and uh we're kind of just superhuman at
every fiddly little optimization problem
we throw it at.
I mean, Spencer had a
decent software background. He just
didn't have an AI background.
low level
Where is he?
I think he's out Spencering at the
moment, which is fine.
Oh, I mean the client Yes, it's like
it's profitable just we've made
everything I've invested back and more.
Um
But just like that like I mean if you're
going to measure it in profitability
then it's even looking worse for the big
labs cuz none of them are profitable.
Ah, there's Spencer.
How's it going, man?
Uh so good news is I'm not logging [ __ ]
incorrectly
for constellation. We just have um
I never tested it with multi-billion
step runs apparently and I we're
overflowing.
We're just overflowing uh for total time
steps, so I'm fixing that.
Uh sweeps and neural MMO seem to be
working decently well.
I do want to get you on boarded Well,
you're already on boarded, but talk
about how we can get set up for um
experiments and stuff.
Yeah, after lunch is good. We can do
that.
That way I get in a short stream on some
dev.
I'll fix constellation.
And then we can handle experiments.
If you want what we can do is we can do
the experiment stuff on stream and then
we can talk about our other stuff off
stream.
The experiment stuff's all public,
right?
Mm, train total time steps. There you
go.
Okay, but like
Oh.
Matrix is not in here.
Down here.
Yeah, we shouldn't have to do this
anyways, right?
Okay, maybe we do. We'll just do horizon
here.
>> What is
What?
Loads.
This name one not found.
One's for over leasing as soon as
possible, likely 2 weeks out.
Barring delays.
Uh I'm getting Spencer to help with
experiments starting today.
We're going to actually discuss that on
stream after he finishes lunch.
All right, guys.
There's the plot.
There value to making other
architectures faster, comps and stuff?
Absolutely.
Uh actually, a fast comp right now,
like it based on the code that we have
in puffer four,
uh a fast comp would be considered a
major contribution.
Because right now, I'm using a shitty
IM2 call.
Uh we have CUDA and N code, but it
doesn't train correctly.
And even the CUDA and N code is pretty
inefficient.
I don't to be clear, I don't actually
know if it's possible to get a fast comp
at this scale.
Um
So, before you go and try to do it, note
that like you might be working on
something that's impossible, and this
probably takes something somebody who's
pretty experienced
um with kernel dev
to do well.
So,
Yay, there we go. Constellation.
It's pretty.
>> Get better at kernel dev? I mean,
honestly, it's just start like start
building some stuff with this, right?
Easiest way to learn.
You can learn very, very quickly if you
have some spare time.
I think we're pretty good at guiding
people.
And we do put effort into um giving
people feedback who put in effort to
like build cool stuff.
Like we're not going to give you a ton
of guidance up front on like do this
this this cuz we already have the
articles. But you know, if you're
building stuff and want feedback on it
and it's like clear you put effort into
it, then yeah, of course.
All right.
Well, uh this works. So
I don't know if Spencer, if you're still
watching, but I'm going to use the rest
remote quick.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> I'm going to use the rest remote quick,
probably get a bench set in, and then I
will be ready to chat about stuff.
Mhm. I'll be right back.
One second.
All right. Let me take 210 first real
quick.
Get more coffee.
Not quite 10 reps.
Yeah, nine.
All right, perfect.
Grab a Spencer here.
Test.
Yo.
You were super quiet.
Hang on.
Say something.
Hello.
Yeah.
That should be good.
I figure we chat uh
about the experiment off on stream and
then we'll chat about everything else
off.
Okie dokie.
All right.
So, uh let's see.
First of all, I got
while uh you were having lunch,
the constellation results.
Here you go.
This fully works.
What is the env in this one? One sec.
Let me zoom in on the
stream.
>> Okay.
So, we got a few decent runs. This is
overnight. Um
You need a lot of
Like the sweeps for neural MMO are just
going to take forever
because
it's 5 to 50 bill steps per run.
Oh, yeah, it's going to take a while. It
is.
Do you have kung stuff in there for the
early cutoff or does that not work with
this?
Yeah, we do.
We do.
Um but still, like it's cool that we
have a few decent runs though.
Uh normally it's very, very hard to
sweep. So, just overnight we have
a few decent ones. I think this is
probably like the uh
the initialization run. Right? Yeah,
5.58
>> 5.58 at 20 uh This is
I had to divide steps by a million cuz
we were overflowing. So, this is 20
bill.
Okay, okay.
I think it's kind of cool that we're
doing steps in millions. You know, RSPS
is your experiment x-axis.
That's fun.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, so um here's the plan, right? Like
there are a couple very small, I'd say,
jank things with
the logging stuff that we're going to
have to probably like we're probably
going to end up having to rerun some of
the sweeps because of it.
Um but I want to basically have the
sweeps for the envs working correctly,
data getting loaded.
So, we know that like even if we have to
rerun stuff, it's literally just press
the button and we're done.
Um Okay.
I'll show you the current sort of state
of stuff. So, it's basically
identical to what I showed you with some
very
minor refactors.
And move tensors into here because
they're used by vec env. Um I still
probably will have to refactor a couple
things, but I think there should be no
more required numerics changes.
Which means you know, stuff will be
nice and easy to repro. Um And you said
you got determinism going again? Yes, it
was evil evil thing yesterday.
Was the uh the sample actions RNG.
We do RNG a little different now.
But if I just show you
>> So, the CUDA NN is not currently used.
And uh puffer net is puffer net. So,
this is under 5K lines.
All right, yeah.
>> Everything.
Um
And I think that the main thing, so I
changed actions back to float.
So, some envs are going to need minor
port changes.
Very, very simple.
Uh I don't think RNG was ported for all
the envs yet either.
It's literally so simple, you can ask
Flo to do it and it'll just work.
Um Okay.
But pretty much what I just want help
doing is like getting all the envs
sweeping with
ideally with metrics that I think most
of them already have perf metrics that
max out reasonably at one.
But we definitely want that. Um
You know, we'd want them to all have
uh episode length and episode return.
Um just basically canonicalization of
envs.
Sweeps, anything that's like jank
happening like you noticed um
What was the end? Our where like that's
got some weird like
>> That one had some weird stuff going on.
There are a couple ends like that. So, I
basically just want some help going
through
those. Uh custom encoders,
I think there are a few ends that
require them,
but not like tons.
But, we do have cons. I'll show you
that.
But, most of them don't need like custom
stuff. Like I think we'll probably be
able to get snake to work without
convert to work without. This will work.
Uh I wouldn't even be surprised if tower
climb worked, honestly.
Like go should probably work.
And like a lot of these will just work,
right?
Mhm. Um I think that
most of the ones that don't just work,
all they need is a one-hot net.
So, you can just make like one one-hot
encode net or whatever.
Um
I guess we could just do one one-hot
encode net, and then that can just be
used for anything that needs it.
Uh I think just try the default net on
stuff first though, cuz honestly it
might just work.
Yeah, I mean that's probably my plan is
at least try and make sure everything at
least runs okay, get it on default. I'll
probably just sweep on default anyways,
cuz it'll be the fastest, and then
if it fails, then we'll do custom nets.
The evil environments that need custom
nets are 1 2 3 4
D6 probably, right?
Yeah, those six Will Does drone need one
or no? I don't remember.
Uh no, drone shouldn't need one. Drone I
haven't tested cuz it's continuous
actions,
but we should be able to have drone
work.
That's actually one of the things you
could help with that actually, or you
could get Finn and Sam to do that.
Um
Yeah, cuz we do have continuous actions
integrated, and there is a squared
continuous end that you can use to test
to make sure it didn't break that.
Um but yeah, drones need integrating.
But, I really just want to have all the
ends in. We can also talk about if we
want to prune any of these.
Most of them are pretty good though.
I would think most of them are pretty
good. I think some of the unlisted ones
we don't need like
we don't have a few different versions
of this convert end for instance
Mhm.
>> probably don't need to mess with.
Um
There are a couple that like aren't
listed that are good. Like grid for
instance isn't listed, but grid is one
of the most important ones.
Uh how many of the experiments did you
want me to run per end? I know we wanted
a larger number this time. Uh default is
1,200 per. 1,200 successful experiments.
We can just leave it at that.
Okay. So, that will mean that you use
the other 6 GPU box.
Yeah.
>> with uh you just run that, and that
actually won't take long for most of
these ends.
Like that'll be a few hours most of
these tops.
2048 actually does well without even a
custom encoder, believe it or not.
Um what do you want me to do with the
results? Like are they Do you want them
stored somewhere now, or export them
somewhere?
>> yeah. So, let me show you how that works
at the moment.
There's a new folder called logs.
Make sure that this is clean. So, like
you know, copy old logs are removed or
whatever.
Yeah.
And this here like it'll just write
stuff to here. You can just zip the logs
folder,
and then if you just unzip the logs
folder on the target machine where we're
building constellation, it'll just like
you know, put all the subdirectories in,
and then cached data just runs on that.
Okay, so you want them all to still be
like
multiple subdirectory ends in the in one
big logs directory.
>> Yeah, but this is I cleaned it up, man.
Like here, I'll show you.
So, this literally just has the curves.
It doesn't have like the models and
stuff in it.
Oh, okay. Okay. So, it doesn't have
Okay, I got you.
Yeah. So, this is like way way better.
Um the loading as well, the loading
caches.
So, if you put more stuff in there,
it essentially just like concatenates
all the JSON files together internally.
Yeah.
>> Um
So, like it loads one big file instead
of tiny files, and then if there are new
tiny files, it will pick them up,
which is nice.
So, it's like a very nice caching. So,
it's it should be very very easy.
Okay.
>> The main thing is basically just I'm
expecting [ __ ] to be fiddly
across these,
and
ideally I'd also like you to have
constellation running locally, so you
can play with it, and like see when
stuff is fiddly.
So, for instance one thing I've noticed
is um
like some experiment for whatever reason
they don't report the losses at eval or
something weird. So, like it'll break
because some we won't have the same
number of keys with losses or something.
So, like
I don't know. Either like if you either
figure out where that happens, or I'll
figure out where it happens and push a
fix. Like there are several small things
like this.
I think right now for instance if you
run a multi GPU training run, not a
multi GPU sweep, but a multi GPU
training run, I think it saves on every
GPU it saves log files, which is jank.
Like there's several small things like
this that we just have to iron out. This
is basically like polish polish, make
experiments work, clean up for release,
and we good.
Okay.
I'll show you the other two as well real
quick.
So, I finished the numerics. I finished
the sweep Oh, yeah, this should It
should not OOM on sweeps as well. If it
OOMs on sweeps, tell me,
cuz I added something that's just
supposed to catch this.
Um
I still need to do perf tests. I'll be
doing that I don't know, today or this
week or whatever.
Custom encoders, you'll do some of this,
I'll do some of this.
Mhm.
>> There's the whole Python 3 5 refactors
to do.
Nothing super tough here, and then
there's some like
Uh I'm planning this cloud installation
finalizing is like part of what we're
doing now, but then there's some minor
cleanups.
Docker I'll do.
We'll talk about this stuff offline
Yeah, yeah. after we're done with this.
And that's like it, man. We'll be done.
We'll be good.
Yeah, that doesn't seem to like really
too bad.
>> Yeah, I think we can [clears throat] be
done We can have this launched in 2
weeks.
Pretty much on time.
>> Which would be really really nice. Um
There's all sorts of cool new stuff to
do after this.
Do you want me on tiny box one or zero?
I'm on zero. Use one.
Okay.
Yeah, oh you will have to probably
install a couple Nvidia packages.
Yeah, I I have four over on my local
machine on one of my own branches, so I
know packages you're talking about.
All right, we're good.
Um
Some stuff going on in the background.
No worries.
There you go. Let me know.
Shh.
Let's see. So,
I'm trying to think if there's anything
else I've missed.
I think that's mostly mostly what we
need. Um
Is there anything here that like doesn't
make sense?
I mean, not in front of my like tasks I
need to accomplish, I don't think like
my plan is very straightforward.
>> make sure that constellation's not
goobering, so we can like
have everything. I guess we can talk
about like the final
what we want for constellation. My idea
of this is essentially that we get
Oh, yeah, the down sample param is also
kind of important
because that's like the number of
points.
We could make it
Maybe this is actually a good thing to
discuss. So, if we do like down sample
uh What was it? Was 10 before the
previous?
It was It's five or 10 depending on the
end, I think.
Um
I cuz I'm trying to think like what the
final thing we want to display is. I
definitely want us to have 100k plus
total points
to present, but I don't want it to be
definitely want to have 10k experiments.
What?
There I don't think there are enough
ends to do 100k if even if you 1,200. We
don't have over like whatever 90 ends or
80 ends. Well, do we have what? 10 or 20
ends?
We got 10 very good ends for sure.
Yeah, I'd say like 10 solid ends, and
then like 10 kind of simpler ones. Mhm.
Maybe [snorts] like 12 good ones, and
then like eight.
Yeah, so I guess we can discuss like
which of these we want to have included
in the sweeps. Cuz like we don't want to
have a sweep for squared or template in
there, right?
For sure.
Um
It is important to have a couple simpler
ends, right? Like just so you can see oh
yeah, this just solves instantly or
whatever.
Like cart pole or whatnot. Cart pole's a
classic.
Um
I mean, we could just run more
experiments on the more exciting ones.
Well, the super short ones, they just
like
They'll just do it instantly.
>> Yeah, exactly. They're just instant
anyways.
But yeah,
even the constellation chart of it just
going to look like a wall of points at
one, basically.
>> [snorts]
>> So, I would think that for any of these
experiments that literally solve in
in like
a couple of seconds, we probably set
down sample to whatever it is, one or
zero. So, it's just the last point.
Right?
Yep.
Because also the curves are noisy and
it's only the final eval that is
meaningful for those anyways.
So,
that Oh, yeah. We'll see whether Pong is
one of those or not. You can remove that
shaped reward thing and see how that
goes.
Um
for that one.
I guess when I say like I want this to
be a data set of at least 100k points,
in my mind that means that like
So, for short runs, one run is one
point.
Uh for long run, it's going to be like
whatever is a decent number of points to
approximate the curve, right?
Like I said here. So, for Let me show
you what I mean.
And this is kind of just going to be a
rough guideline, but like So, for Neural
MMO, I set it to 50.
I think this is two runs on top of each
other, which is why this looks so dense.
Arguably, I could have set this to like
20 or whatever, but I don't think five
would have been enough for Neural MMO.
For like a, you know, multi like tens of
billions of steps run.
Um
also the
So, what we're doing now is the
down-sampled points are both used to
train
the um
to train the sweep algorithm, and then
they're also logged to constellation.
So, this is like the whole curve of the
one experiment logged to constellation,
right?
So, that's same parameters being used on
both?
Yes.
Okay.
Because it is it's kind of what you
want, right? Like the number of It's You
want a decent number of points to
approximate the curve.
So, yeah. I think then like anywhere
between maybe 50 for Neural MMO, but
everything else is probably going to be
between like 1 and 20 or something.
Um I think that with that, we probably
will end up with around 100,000 like
points worth of data
for constellation. And then we will
basically will be able to decide you
know, whether we want to shift the whole
100k to web if that's fast, or if we
want to do like the Pareto optimal of
those points to web. Um we can do either
of those.
Uh I the data format should be pretty
nice such that we can recompute a bunch
of different stuff and change the
visualizations without having to rerun
unless we make any major mistakes.
Um Like for instance, this t-SNE here.
Like these points are super bright
because it's t-SNEing all the points
from each run on top of each other
because it's not including total time
steps in the t-SNE, but I can change the
t-SNE computation without rerunning the
experiments, you see?
Mhm.
Just stuff like that.
I think that the most important ones I
want to definitely have
So, I'd love to have We want Grid for
sure, which we should probably rename to
Maze.
The Maze, but we want Grid.
>> yeah. Yeah.
We want Grid. We want Demo for that. Um
Neural MMO, of course.
Uh Simple M's, Breakout, Pong for sure.
We definitely want Tetris on there. We
want 2048.
Uh Some of these other ones I think are
quite nice as well.
Like we should have all of them, but as
first the gold set.
It might be nice to have like our top 10
environments as the gold set or
whatever.
Um I mean, I don't see any reason why I
can't just
I'm wondering if
>> like kept on throwing? I mean, I don't
know why I mean, I don't think it'll be
that bad.
I don't mean delete them, but I mean
like So, if we're going to if we're
going to say like, "Hey, this is a
benchmark for whatever." Right? We
should I think for Four Row, we report
the results on all the M's cuz we have
all the M's. But like Right.
>> going to want to test an algorithm in
the future, it would be nice to have a
high confidence set like subset that we
just say, "Yeah, we run
>> Yeah. these five or these 10, and these
are like the high quality M's that we've
used for a bunch of stuff."
And you're fine with on each of the
quote high quality M's having, if there
is a necessary encoder for that one, to
include that as part of the benchmark,
or only on default for everything? No,
if it if the net if the environment's
obs don't make sense with the default
encoder, then it can have a custom
encoder. That's fine.
Okay. I think it's a point in the
environment's favor if it doesn't need
one.
Right? Well, sure.
Um
I mean, I I think top 10 on this visual
is fine, but I may pick a couple that I
just like as well. Yeah, go ahead.
>> that are like more interesting.
Yeah.
And basically just see what we get out
of the sweeps, like
you know, if stuff is janky,
then we definitely want a couple
multi-agent ones in there for sure.
I think that's kind of it as far as I
have. It's mostly just like a bunch of
finicking with these, and then I have to
figure out
I have to make sure that I don't have
anything screwy in constellations. I'll
probably figure out that loss bug, and
I'll figure out a couple other small
things for this.
Um
I will keep the Neural MMO sweep running
until we have stuff for that. I'll
probably like try to keep getting for a
little bit a better Neural MMO policy
cuz I just think that would be nice to
have for the release.
Um and then if that starts taking too
long, I'll just, you know, use the
current one, and we'll I'll just start
uh devoting that box to the other M's as
well if I like finish the other core
refactors by then. Cuz I think you said
the Python training is broken or
whatever.
Last time I tried it, it was broken,
yes. Okay, yeah. So, I'll fix the Python
training, and then also it's like
it's basically duped with um
the
like Puffer RL train code. So, I'm going
to see if I can use the same train
harness for the Python trainer and the C
trainer. That might be nice.
Mhm. I'll probably like fix up a couple
things. I'm going to delete all of the
I think I delete all of the like Python
bind files, right?
For sure. Yeah, all of those can be
removed. So, you basically just access
the M's through the VecEnv interface
now?
And I I can also like the VecEnv
interface, I can also add it so you can
make one env or whatever. But for the
Python binding version, it still does
goes through the VecEnv, yeah? And it's
still not requiring of the
Yeah. So,
>> the bindings anymore?
>> right right now in 3.0, uh 3.0 is Python
bind per env, and then Python bind goes
to Python vec. What I'm going to do is
for our native M's, no Python bind, C
all the way through vec. But we can make
it so that like, you know, with vec, you
could just set one env or whatever, and
you could set it like local with no
threading, and then you get the same
thing. But you still get rid of all the
bind files regardless, all the uh the
Python bind files.
So, one less thing to maintain. Are we
still keeping the C bind files for for
the Python
version?
>> No, cuz that's still required.
>> aren't for the Python version. The C
bind files are required for everything.
They look different now, man.
Yeah.
>> Like here.
Like they don't have There's no pi
There's no Python C API in here. So,
there's still a binding file, but it's
for vec now. It's not for Python.
So, have you messed with Grid one where
you had to do some like shared uh
resources amongst
copies of M's?
Yeah?
>> I did mess with it. Let me see.
It probably needs updating since the
latest thing for Flo and stuff, but it
was just like this.
Okay.
No.
Yeah, this looks fine. Okay.
>> I don't think it's any more complex than
before, and you get rid of the Python
API.
We can get rid of these act types. We
don't use act type anywhere. We do use
the obs tensor T.
Uh I know that a couple of them cuz of
Claude added obs types. I'll get re-
remove those things as well.
Yeah. Just obs tensor T.
Yep. I wasn't just cuz of Claude. That
was cuz that was legitimately a thing in
an earlier version. Um
I think that's
Yeah, that's most of the work associated
with this.
Um And I I know I still have that one
mystery bug on Drive that for some
reason was injecting something ahead of
obs tensor T. I'll see [snorts] if I'll
I'll hopefully see if that only applied
to that env versus any others.
>> Yeah, I just like you can add that to
the setup for now, and we'll see if we
can find something better.
Um
It would be very nice to have Drive in
here, I will say.
Yeah, I mean, I'm going to try and at
least get it in there. I mean, Drive was
actually did fairly well even on the
default encoder. It didn't get to like
the same level as with the custom net,
but
it just basically took a lot longer.
Yeah. [snorts]
Well, I wonder if it takes longer now in
wall clock because
we can probably run that env really
fast. Um, I think there's going to be
some stuff we can do with drive and I
have some plans for that after the
release.
Um,
if we just get a
like if we just get a a 16-bit float
type
for instance in C, which can easily have
one of those. It's just bit packing.
Um,
you know, we could even store it in
Bfloat16 the same format and then just
transfer it.
Uh, that cuts the bandwidth in half.
That probably gets the drive SPS up to
like 3 mil.
Just right there.
Yeah, cuz the raw end fire call goes
like two something mil, I want to say
2.5 like if you just step through it.
Yeah, it was mostly the bandwidth.
So, it was really just like the
bandwidth plus the custom net with the
like the entity encoder stuff. Yeah.
That was really the brutality of it.
Um,
other stuff for sweeps.
I think I I pushed this to you just make
sure.
We want to do
>> 4.0. Yeah, not not like another branch
name. Still on 4.0.
Okay.
>> Uh, I have So, I have more stuff
sweeping now.
You can see if I have any weird ranges.
Ah, look, I cut it out here for some
reason. This is not good.
This should not be commented.
It's supposed to be 16.
Eight to like
like something like this.
Just add that.
Um, do we want to take out the wild
ranges like the clip coefficients of 0.1
and some of like the really unstable
ones or do you want to keep those in?
Um, so what I want to do with that
What I would like to do is
uh, this is why I want you to have part
of the reason why I want you to have
constellation up while you're doing this
stuff.
Um,
so I want to see if any of the sweeps on
the ends with the nice new stable 4.0
are still finding a bunch of runs over
there and getting stuck on it.
Okay. Yeah, cuz that tells us something
important, right?
Yep.
I'll do most of it on my office computer
then so I can actually pull up
constellation nicely.
>> So,
>> [snorts]
>> you should be doing the sweeps on the
six GPU box, right? So, it's fast.
And then all you have to do is you just
like zip logs.zip. No, logs zip-r logs
what zip-r logs.zip logs, right? And
then you SC Yeah, zip the logs, send it
send it over to my machine and then
>> data and you run dot slash
constellation.
Uh, is there is it a build script to run
constellation or
>> Yes, I'll show you the process right
now.
So, this is cash data.py. You just put
the uh,
the end names in here.
Okay. So, these are like directories of
the logs that we zipped. Yes, so like
python cash data
and if there's weird stuff with this,
let me know cuz I've been screwing with
this. And then bash scripts build ocean
constellation. There's local and there's
fast. This requires cJSON.
You just like drop the cJSON.h and
cJSON.c into the constellation
directory.
I didn't commit it.
I don't think it is committed. Last time
I tried to run a bash script. Yeah, it's
literally just Google cJSON. It's like a
25 project.
>> just that file. Okay, so it's both H and
C.
>> Yeah, that's it. We might vendor it.
We'll see.
For now, that's okay. Yeah.
dot slash constellation
I'm just going to make sure to have that
in the final version.
Uh, I might do the thing where like when
you run setup.py it downloads for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, so it doesn't bloat like the repo
steps and stuff.
>> Same thing as we do with Raylib. Yeah, I
think probably we'll do that. We'll see.
And yeah, I think this is basically the
plan as over the next early part of the
week. This gets cleaned up a little bit.
The cash data gets cleaned up. Like
little things from the training get
cleaned up so that it's stable logs.
Python side gets cleaned up. We can even
run a couple sweeps on there to make
sure it matches,
right?
Mhm. Uh, cuz I think the python side is
going to be important in the sense that
like it lets us test ideas very quickly
if you just want to like go grab a thing
from a paper.
Right? Uh, yeah. I mean that's what I've
been experimenting with that other
architecture I sent you. Um, so I just
dropped that into the python version and
then
let it run and then if if it seems to do
well, then make a kernel so it's faster.
Yeah.
I think that's a fine way to to have it
and then we'll see basically in the
future if tinygrad really catches on,
then maybe we'll be able to swap that
for tinygrad and we'll like just be able
to drop the entire bloated depths, which
would be nice.
Um, tinygrad has no depths. It's really
cool.
Um,
but for now I don't think it's mature
enough and I think people just use
pytorch so I think that's the right
call.
Just pytorch.
Yep.
I can get more kernel dev practice in.
Be useful. Uh, that's one of the major
things I want to do as well cuz like
I've kind of just
muddled my way through
and uh, I there's definitely some stuff
I need to still learn.
Okay, I think we're good on all this,
right? Anything else to discuss on the
uh,
on this side stuff?
>> On this on this subject, I do
not think so. I'll let you know if I run
into any issues on the actual process
like if one of the steps is broken, but
uh, outside of that I think it should be
fine. Okay, so should I just like I'll
end stream and we can do admin stuff? Or
you want to do that later?
>> I mean I'm sure we we can do that now if
you're cool with just killing the stream
now.
>> on. Let me just uh,
Yeah, so for folks watching, thanks for
tuning in. I'll be streaming more this
probably Monday. Tomorrow's day off.
Um, puffer.ai for all the things. Star
puffer on GitHub. It's free. It helps us
out a ton.
Launch in hopefully two weeks and join
Discord in the link below.